[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the
great columnist for the cleveland plain
dealer terry pluto joining us
why do you think we moved up the time
frame here terry well
i don't i don't necessarily think that
they're going to be having a new name
in 21. you know whether they decide to
you know be the cleveland blanks or
uh or they're going to stay with the
indians i know in july the original plan
was to have like one
last year with the indians uh you know
sell stuff all that kind of thing
um and also as a top executive told me
dan you know this it's easy to say okay
we're not gonna be the indians it's hard
to say well what are you gonna be
i mean i just got how about the walleyes
that that just came in
you feel strongly about fish
what about tribe oh no nothing to do
with the native american they want to
get as far away from that
okay all right i love tribe fact i often
call them my story the try far more than
the uh
uh the indians a long time i guess the
book's the old is not really a big plug
i wrote a book called our tri but how
basically is how the indians were like a
second family to my
my dad and i growing up and he talked
about bob feller like you talked about
you know uncle myron and that's how i
think the feeling is when you are
in a you know we have a close
association with the team it's kind of
like a tribe that goes across
well i love about sports racial lines
and everything else
but also we see what's happening with
washington and the football team and
daniel snyder and
i i understand what he's doing
i guess um could you see the cleveland
baseball team
as a possibility sort of a step uh stop
gap or band-aid
uh or kind of ride this out it feels
like daniel steiner is like all right
you want me to change it how about
that i'm going to change it to that i
mean i always see the revenue stream
here with terry
uh terry that you're like we'll get a
new nickname and we got
all brand new revenue stream here
yeah that would be the idea a year from
now but i'm not sure the cleveland
baseball team is going to
sell a lot of sweatshirts i could be
wrong but that doesn't do it for me
i know this in july when i wrote the
story that
it was not going to be till 22 uh the
plan at that point
was for um them to be the last year with
the indians in the same same year like
they
and they had like kind of one last go
around with chief wahoo
so that was the plan uh it could change
you know things have been really subject
to that but the moment dan the moment
they came out said we're thinking about
changing your name
yeah i don't know why people are
surprised it was done you don't come out
and say that say ah never mind we're not
gonna do that
you know we're gonna we're gonna go back
i thought we'd go back to the old 1948
logo which was really our principle no
they're not going to do that
so uh it's just a matter of what and i
think that is really their big
you know discussion area and on top of
it you know right now the indians are in
a major
budget cutting thing um it's really
funny though
in cleveland it's like the indians are
held to this higher standard than the
other franchises
with the fans you know the last i think
they've last eight years they've had
winning records gone the playoffs five
times
uh but they're cheap but
are we looking at the braves now the
chiefs the blackhawks
is it going to be college is it high
school like the the trickle down
uh does it does it start with the
cleveland indians
i mean that could be the next you know i
wrote a
the first comment i wrote about chief
wahoo was 1996
where i was against getting rid of i
mean i was for changing the logo
uh and but keeping the name because i've
been out west a lot
especially at the wind river indian
reservation which is what it's called
and then back then uh and for many years
they had a kind of a paper from usa
today called the indian country today
indian was not considered that
pejorative a term you know redskins
always was but
indian was but they did not like the
logo and so i always kind of base my
uh thing on that granted boy there's a
real depth poll
i get it but in terms of just common
sense
but now i mean truthfully as you said it
could go into anything that
you know florida state i just saw them
playing basketball the other day with
that big logo on the floor i
i thought the same thing you did dan i
mean i don't know what
what what it is but um
it's one of those things i guess because
i grew up with it you know
i i feel for it but i was really down on
the logo for years what i wanted them to
do was actually hire
like four or five top of the native
american uh artist to have them do a
rendering of it
have a big contest and you know money
get tossed around
i think people would have liked that now
it's i'll tell you it is wide open
what's your id
what do you want to name you're from
dayton right you're from ohio oh
i don't know the the the cleveland
buckeyes how's that
yeah i mean it was a that was a negro
league team yeah it's not bad some
people don't like because
because it follows with ohio state you
know your marketing brand there
um i don't like the spiders everybody
wants the spiders yeah that's that's the
big thing
they have a lobbying group going you
know the cleveland spiders which the
last time they were the spiders they
were just
awful so that's back in what i thought
1899 cleveland spider yeah i covered
them
they really had some nice guys but they
just couldn't play you know
they really but it was really bad at the
end they actually
did bring in this bill hop when they
said he could pitch because they were
running out of pitchers or on the road
somewhere and
found out he fished like a bellhop um
how big of an issue is this locally
big it's a big deal because uh
but is there a fan a lot of fans i'm
sure
don't want change yes but
are they a vocal group is it a large
group that doesn't
doesn't want it yeah how much is it
going to hurt the attendance or whatever
i don't know but in terms of first of
all it strikes me
that most of the fans of the baseball
team tend to be older
and i think some of the demographics
have shown that other places
so one they're used to what you know you
and i are a little older we're used to
what we're used to
and change sometimes doesn't do it for
us
uh and thirdly like a lot of them like
the tribe
or that i think they they weren't
thrilled about the logo
but the name thing is really kind of
rocked them
and they feel that it's being pressured
you know from uh
manford and the league office to
everything that's going on in the world
right now
and now they want to take away the
teen's name and call it
who knows yeah but i go back to the
chicago blackhawks i think it's maybe
the finest
looking like it's it's gorgeous that
logo
is beautiful and if you do it in
conjunction i agree with you if i look
at the braves and the indians
i those those are that's a threatening
looking
caricature i mean it's not it's not
flattering at all if i was native
american
and i think if you do it in a regal way
in conjunction with some native american
artists
then you probably could have
circumvented this a long time ago terry
hopefully although i mean some people
i mean it all depends where we are
politically on stuff but
i'm with you dan and i always thought
too that
hey get some money involved here as i
said you have those renderings of that
and
you know say the guy that won it is is
from the lakota
um by the way that's one of the things
when you're out west you discover that
the identity is your tribe you know
the arapaho the lakota the the shawnee
whatever
that you know that tribe gets a piece of
the action from whoever won this i just
think it could have been fun
but they just decided that's it in the
middle of this year
um the other thing they were worried
about
and the washington had this was a lot of
corporate sponsors remember went after
them and it's not like cleveland's got a
ton of corporate
sponsors of fortune 500 companies to
begin with and i think they didn't want
their sponsors feeling a lot of pressure
to push towards this so they wanted to
get out in front of it
yeah but you think this
this year last year enjoying the uh the
artist formerly known as the cleveland
indians
yes unless they decided to make them the
cleveland blanks which i hope they don't
do that
terry good to talk to you as always keep
stirring it up we appreciate your time
as always
thank you dan that's uh terry pluto
columnist for the cleveland plane dealer